[Music]
his words verbally
the Muslim brother
you know there is two way you can do it
you can't do it verbally and you can do
it physically
[Music]
my mother
you're gonna really you know stop what
the Bible said the Bible said
Peacemaker because they are called
children of God no problems
the trouble with his mouth with his
mouth we have to be careful what to say
to our teachers that will make a man get
angry so who started to the fight is
about and they're gonna run
even even tourism
[Laughter]
and I
foreign
[Music]
because no doubt is an individuals here
mentally Disturbed they will say
anything either we have to carry your
discussion of the meditation or walk
away from them that's what I do you
understand all right do you watch do you
watch this football match when you see
that they didn't see that in the World
Cup you remember yeah and
[Music]
walk away
no no no no
[Music]
Moses and the Torah that we have our
Bible based upon so one thousand years
we don't know the writers we don't know
the translators if we don't know them
how can we trust them we cannot trust
them
so why are you following a book you
cannot just
do this
was written by a man inspired by God
can you trust someone you don't know now
I can't trust somebody okay
the early smart script that we have for
the Old Testament is one thousand years
God okay so so one thousand years God
which is this course one thousand years
Gap someone came and he started saying
Jesus said and Moses before sorry Moses
said this Jeremiah said that do we know
him who do not know him if we don't know
him can we trust him now watch us now
can you trust me no no we can't trust
her my weekend no no Jeremiah
no the scribes the one who wrote the
Bible that that is caused he was written
by scribes they came one thousand years
after Moses yes 100 years after Jeremiah
yes we don't know them
spread they will tell you we don't know
them yeah we have to trust them if we
don't know that no no we can't trust
them
when they are right man write the Bible
by the way they moved by the Holy Spirit
inspired by God why they move by the
holy spirit so if you like so if you
look if you look and our lives I know
and and all we live four engineers in
slavery and if you read the Bible what's
going on today in the world how what's
going on about prayer there's a prophecy
now the prophecy so we can see what's
going on in the world and what's written
in the Bible it is true so when we're
talking about other prophets when we're
talking about all the prophets that's in
the Bible everything that was written in
the Bible is coming to fulfill so can we
trust the Bible yes can you can you
don't
wrestling with the claim you said
there's a prophecy who's been fulfilled
Allah
the Hebrew Israelite especially this
movement starts in Harlem America people
it's a lie that the true Hebrew is like
are black people this movement doesn't
make any sense no way because they
believe they were enslaved in the people
before if they were saving the people
before those people are going to claim
to be the truth is the light they're
gonna say because you know why we are
the truth is alive because the Bible
said we're going to be enslaved so it's
a game though that's the first thing not
every prophecy is being fulfilled in the
Old Testament that's the first thing
secondly many prophecies in the Old
Testament came after that came before
for example uh the only smallest people
to have one thousand years yes one
thousand years after Moses so he's
saying something only happened that's
not a prophecy you understand prophecy
when you give me a scripture about dated
Moses time prophesizing something yes
and by the way I'm not negating that I'm
not saying everything in the Bible is
corrupted no
can we trust the Bible that was written
by people we don't know we cannot and we
can prove within we don't know the five
books was given to Moses correct which
is judging to me okay if the five books
was given to Moses at the end of uh
you're showing me he says Moses died in
the land of Moab and he was 100 over 100
or something and Israelites cried for
him since then there was no Prophet like
Moses this passage is clearly was
written way after Moses because he says
since then there was no Prophet like
Moses so do you know who that position
foreign
that it says Moses died in the letter q
app it was 150 years old the Israelites
fight for him and since then there was
no Prophet like Moses if you die today I
cannot say what's your name again
if you die today Venezuela I cannot save
here
I can't always say since then there was
no man like man in Israel because people
say with me since then that guy just
died for your own but since then
indicate what a long time so my point
you know when you look but it doesn't
matter
everything everything that I read in the
Bible
supposed to be written while the
moderators inspired by God which means
they profits them that wrote the Bible
there's so many problems
you said Israelites that we believe we
don't believe nothing we know
by the way as a Muslim would we use this
term we say believe is based upon not
just knowledge based upon certainty
because sometimes sometimes sometimes
something can be based upon knowledge
but the person doesn't have certainty so
we as Muslims when you use the word
belief mean knowledge and certainty bye
brother understand my points I agree
Jeremiah was inspired by God that news
inspired by God Moses in that but what
I'm saying what they've been inspired
with the scriptures we don't have the
original writing we have the writing
that came after
hundred years after one thousand years
after I was written by people who don't
know them and guess what bro but these
are you in your own Bible your God or
the most high yokos my God no doubts
about that even though you speak bad
about it in the Bible I'll mention it
later but the most high already said in
the Old Testament that the Israelites
they're evil people there are pagans
that turn away from God how can we trust
people that God many times rebuked them
Jeremiah 8 8 what does he say you know
what he says something you know what he
says yes or no
no
he says how can we claim that we have
the law with us when the pen of the
scribes have changed it alone we are in
Jeremiah say that I understand eight
eight yeah okay he says how can we claim
that we have spread how could we claim
we have the Torah with us we understand
the lion scribes have changed it and
that's what Allah that's what shows you
I something
is for you the Quran For All Mankind no
no no no no yeah
remember my favorite on you right same
thing the current is for you
what listen to this yeah
when you said when you said me and you
are the same God who are not the one day
because guess what I believe
I said are different yeah because the
Bible
you know you trust the Quran yes and I
trust my Bible yes
the Old Testament now listen to this no
no no no no no no no no no no no no
all right
listen to me
and when you look at when you look at
certain
um thing about Islam and how it's
respectively and all you know the lady's
restaurant you can accept that
Yeshua so I have a current I may have a
Bible and I don't disrespect none of the
books so when you read the Quran you
understand the Bible and when you read
the Bible you understand the current
good and I truly believe that you're a
prophet Muhammad peace Prophet peace be
upon him he was trying to do good among
his people now listen we never come to
talk to you about that topic I want his
computer
comes back you know the first time I'm
gonna make it quick
you know you know our Muslim Scholars
because we don't believe the Bible that
we have it now right is the original
word of God it's been corrupted can we
step on it he said no you're not allowed
to step on it that's our Muslims call it
you understand because it's still it's
kind of disrespect people's familiar
books you understand so what I was going
to say okay
what I'm saying to you what I just did
I'll show you from outside sources from
within the Bible sources that the Bible
there's corruption and cannot be trusted
and you trust it because you are looking
at the Bible something a submission of
your heritage as a Hebrew Israelite and
into Quran Allah
remember my favor upon you remember the
faith upon you but what is Allah why is
Allah's promise to many Israel
Israelites
fulfill my promise I will fulfill yours
what is the promise Allah that there
will be a messenger coming after that is
upon you to Aid him you understand
Prophet Muhammad is in Isaiah 42. speaks
about the prophet Muhammad okay and that
one saying look into it you keep me
trusty trusted I know Jalan was inspired
but I'm saying the Bible that we have
now that is Bible right based upon a
manuscript that was written 1000 Years
afterwards
tried to correct the Bible yes you know
why because just wrong because
they don't want that they don't want the
original people to know you try you try
God
we know the truth then Israel you listen
both in the Bible said you try oh you
know the truth we know is
it is
stay yeah
no they're trying to corrupt they've
already told they're corrupted no no no
no I've told him I've told him already
yeah there's certain things I do except
in the Bible yes
when Moses said the first commandment to
worship for the Lord that goes Allah
with the Quran in the stand but what I'm
saying what I'm saying when you look to
certain things in the Bible it goes in
line with reality you cannot deny it you
understand but doesn't mean everything
is right but my point here when I use
Isaiah 42 it came away before Prophet
Muhammad so it cannot be written by
Prophet Muhammad likewise he cannot be
written by people that they will there
will be enemies of prophet Muhammad and
speaking he will be a prophet of God
I told you
there's certain things I accept in
Isaiah yes yes
I like media certain things
do you accept in the Bible when God said
to kill the babies and children for the
sins that was done 500 years before they
were born
it's on you the reason
the second time yes because the
treatment of Israel the children of
Israel
is they push us to the worship ball okay
and that's why the moon says to go and
kill them and wipe them out because they
push up because he was with enemies
go and kill them why boys all of them
because because
and they met the children of Israel sing
against God so God said yeah
[Music]
the next piece yeah yeah some you the
reason several seconds
yes it's a signal first one of them it
says God set the sword yes but God said
to Samuel that God has anointed Soul as
a king over the Israelites no and he
said go kid the Malik why because 500
years before when the Israelites were
coming out the ancestors blocked them
from coming out of Egypt
God he said to kill the babies alive to
sort of them alive what babies gonna do
because no no because it's a seed abuka
is the most side we went foreign
it says
contradiction yes that's my point of
establishing to you do you know
God of Israel no no stop talking about
the shouting I speak loud and when I
speak there
yeah
listen to me no listen to me listen to
me listen to me better I'm not sure
lordy this is
the Old Testament
that is there is conflict
okay in the New Testament it's not about
the poor said it's not about your your
actions
it's not about faith it's not about the
law it's about faith that's why you
don't get circumcised the Christians
they never circumcised because Paul said
about circumcision of the heart but in
the Old Testament all the prophets are
messages and Israelite be circumcised
right secondly the Old Testament teach
you if you commit sin you'll be
responsible for your own sins in the New
Testament teach you Jesus would die for
your sins that's contradiction hear me
out in the Old Testament teaches you
anyone that has been hungry or crucified
is cursed
is cursed in the New Testament who has
been handed According To Jesus Paul said
Jews became cursed okay okay so
contradiction okay let me let me just
tell them what's the circumcision and
then you jump to cool no I'm sure
I didn't jump I'm showing your points
the contradiction so but as I want to
pick up on the uh on the phone you said
about four minutes
so you are saying that in this new
testament you don't have to circumcise
yeah
okay but why not
because both churches teaching of God
okay because in the Old Testament the
decision was given to Abraham for a
reason no it's not just for Abraham for
all it's awesome
in the Old Testament God said
circumcision is a sign between me and my
people yes and I will bless those are
sacrificed so all the prophets are
messengers including Jesus understood
circumcision is
everyone understood circumcision is
actually of the private part all of them
including Jesus except for who came
after he said no
so who is Right Jesus so what you were
saying
to the law of the Old Testament
according to the law of Abraham yeah and
also because Muslims they are abrahamic
you have to circumcise yeah you must do
it but in the New Testament you don't
yes so that's the reason why you say
that in the New Testament you don't
pole and what they said in the
Corinthians and it says that you don't
have to obey the law is that what you're
saying yeah
Covenant between the children of Israel
and also have Judah and this New
Covenant is not going to be like the
whole one and we're gonna place it
inside our way out and he will be our
God and will be his people so therefore
when we use the circumcise when a
circumcised against circumcised inside
one inside our heart and it will place
our laws
so when we use a circumcise
who was right who understood that God's
commandment correct
including Jesus understood God's
Commandments of the Christian
circumcision is the actual circumcision
food and the students some of the hearts
so who is right who is the prophet of
God if in Abraham or fort
which one
all of them you tell them
to the Lord
Jesus awkward look I'm telling you that
in the old time
and he's Offspring yes
I don't disagree with that I don't
disagree with that I'm not disagree
all of them and one of them
resident circumcision
killing one of them is killing animals
but because he came after the Lamb of
God and he shed his blood
yeah
no it's not
himself but I'm gonna show you the text
itself before they claim you know I'm
gonna show you I'm not trying to like
English
Old English
all right
fortitude
41 touch
I uphold
behold myself
was spared upon him okay he shall bring
fourth judgment today gentiles
who are the Gentiles the non-jews okay
all right that's one point they're not
juice all of them they're not interested
not juice yes okay he should not cry not
lift up nor cause his voice to be hurt
in the streets Never Gonna shout at
anyone ever gonna scream in anyone
that's never going to curse anyone
no I said he's gonna kill you yeah okay
yeah
but I want to show you guys many here it
says breathe read shall he not big break
as smoking flux should he not quench he
shall bring fourth judgment into the
truth he shall not fail no this they'll
be discouraged till he have such
judgments Jesus he never said judgment
when he was here so they cannot be about
him because Jesus he was scared from
people let alone
so we go step by step so firstly he will
be not be discouraged until he will
establish judgments that cannot be about
Jesus because we know Jesus he did not
establish his judgment he was scared for
his life and the romance they will have
the power over him so what is the
Judgment wait wait wait I'm gonna come
I'm gonna come to it okay okay
that he gave a breath onto the people
upon it and spirit to them that walk
there in so it gives breath and gave
Spirit did Muhammad give breath no he's
speaking about God now that's why he
says God now not not Muhammad
by worshiping God
yeah
you served by worshiping God
the point is
no it's definitely for the people he's
going to be he said no no no this is my
seventh it's on my seventh and that's
the serve them
I want you to be honest otherwise I'm
gonna leave okay
God said is my servant so that man is
the servant of God or not yes
yes that's what my question is
servant of God my question is what is a
servant whether before we tell you what
is suffering no no no
it doesn't say suffering here he says he
will bring Justice he's gonna make
people suffer but by bringing Justice I
guess which Justice are you talking
about Justice worshiping God alone do
not worship idols following God's
teaching correctly not manipulating
people like the Israelites was doing in
the Old Testament but but you have to
let me finish then we'll come step by
step okay to make it clear to you Noah
all of this yeah let the witness and its
cities therefore lift up their voice the
village that Keda does inhabited
I don't know okay so here is
Genesis 25 13 will tell you who are they
you see I'm using your own Bible to show
you to teach you about the Bible Genesis
25 13.
yeah even Hebrew already
yeah okay
Chinese not very far not very lucky 25
13 yeah let us go 25 13. and these are
the names of the sons of Ishmael the
size of who is hear them now by their
names according to their generation the
first born of Ishmael then
and this man he said God says here let
the witness and the cities therefore
lift up their voice the village that
Keda don't inhabit let the inhabitants
of a rock sink he has been mistranslated
because he says let their habits of
Salah inhabits inhabitants
yes sing and we know we Prophet Muhammad
came this Harbor Rejoice but did they
sing yeah there's a narration they will
rejoice in so yeah but but Muslims are
not known for being singers
in general terms you know that music and
singing is forbidden no no thinking
it's instrumental yeah yeah
here
is
when you go down to Isaiah yeah I mean
Isaiah hey Isaiah 42 is separate from
the other one he's speaking about
specific person here yeah
who's above this man who is this man who
is bringing Justice to the Gentiles
Muhammad use this passage to show
Prophet Muhammad is in the Torah so I'm
not the first person to use it by the
way so you're actually saying that that
passage of Isaiah Muhammad and it's not
above Jesus
Son of God what you are saying is Jesus
Son of God or seven of God
he's both
so he got according to scripture yes
[Laughter]
according to the scripture Jesus is not
God let me tell you the reason why so
it's not called YouTube according to the
scripture according to the scriptures
of
they say hello
and then all of a sudden these three men
they came and then he bowed down to them
and frustrated with them and he called
this man God said the Lord that's the
Lord and then he told the young man that
was with him going fetch a little coffee
go prepare some food for the Lord that
appeared as three men what are we
talking about here
you say that Isaiah yeah
if you say that you've made that
statement but you have to agree with me
because you believe Jesus Is God but
here is the servant of God God is Not
servant of God God is no seven of no one
show me doesn't say that at all in the
Bible what is in the Bible that Jesus
himself he submits to God people submit
to God serveth mean you serve yourself
I'm gonna tell you has to be in the Old
Testament because you said that you
don't agree with with most of the things
that the Bible says
you cannot Escape
what are you doing now you just jump
into said Jesus and we can serious about
Jesus
establish judgments when he came
foreign
intellectually rationally logically
Jesus cannot be in Isaiah 42 because
Isaiah 42 speaking about his servant
will not be discouraged until he
establishes
until he established Justice
Jesus never established Justice for
himself he was killed he couldn't you
believe no doubt also even which I
believe if he was okay he'd not bring no
justice to to the John's house is it
clear-cut
you said you said
that uh
yes and this new judgment is to worship
only one God however
very quick yeah and if you let me get
the Bible again yes but if you go
Abraham he worshiped only one Lord even
worship three Gods he worshiped only one
Lord is that Jesus or the father
well in according to the Old Testament
thank you very much
Abraham said that Abrams met and spoke
with the Lord
like a man three of them and two of them
no they said the Angels they're not good
no two of them were angels and the other
one was the Lord and then when you
follow up with that you're going to the
next bit he's actually talking about the
cousin of Abraham who was it was a lot
who was in uh yeah and the same thing
happened to him it was sitting outside
the gate and he saw two angels come and
then he prostrated and he said look
these are the Angels of the Lord so
there's no God okay but God stayed
behind with Abraham
and in Germany
Jesus said your onions were foreign
foreign
[Laughter]
yes
and I say to you that this is actually a
prophecy about the Messiah it cannot be
better okay we have a disagreement it's
okay but no no no it's not bad scream
it's not it's about reality that's the
reality go in line with your statement
with my statement the reality of course
you statement Jesus never brought
Justice to the Giant's house he couldn't
bring Justice to himself he couldn't
bring Justice to his followers they were
oppressed they were scared for their
lives logically it's not about Jesus
that's the first one second one you
believe Jesus Is God he is a servant of
God in the Quran Allah said
when the servants to upon him you know
as subhanallah
praise be to Allah who took his servants
secondly thirdly also he says here he is
let the people of a KW Choice the people
of Keda is the lineage of Ishmael
Prophet Muhammad is a name
you prove Jesus
oh Jesus
is God
how about Isaiah 42 where are you going
come on
no no no
42.
he independently prophecy a man
thank you
and that's it
Jesus Jesus was a manafort who is the
manafort prophet Muhammad of justice and
just oppression not the world of
Oppression against Justice
what are you looking for there's a part
there that says he shall be bruised
through his iniquities that the Judgment
of the earth should be upon his
shoulders and brother why is it 42. hi
guys
so only this part here is that you agree
nothing else about Isaiah no no no no
before that agree or not I'm so I'm
saying to you Isaiah 42 so you're saying
Isaiah 42. nothing else you said Isaiah
42 about Jesus my question I already
passed you is
something I've only asked if Jesus God
on the servant of God he said it's God
so you cannot be Jesus because he has
said it's a servant of God if Jesus came
to establish justice he didn't establish
justice for himself he was oppressed and
killed according to you believe and his
followers they will get for their lives
established Justice to his followers let
alone to the Gentiles the one who did
the history speaking from the Islamic
sources and not Islamic sources
because this passage was used by the
Israelites Muhammad to accept the
Prophet Muhammad
[Laughter]
to all that you have
all right